let's think a little bit about the
different clues that have led us to
conclude that we have these lithospheric
plates moving relative to each other now
the first clue this is something that i
think many students even in elementary
school first experience when they first
learn about geography is it looks like
the continents could kind of fit into
each other and the most obvious one of
these is when you look at this kind of
little pointy part of south america and
if you have a more detailed map it
really is amazing how well it seems to
fit into this into the nigerian basin
right here in africa it looks like at
one time this little pointy part was
nudged into this part of africa that
they were actually connected and if
you're a little bit more creative there
are other parts of the world that you
can kind of start to see how they might
have fit to fit in with each other in
the past and that you know that by
itself that's just a very small clue but
it it kind of hints at well maybe the
you know if they want at one time were
fitting were next to each other or if
this was kind of connected then they've
had to moved apart at some time although
it doesn't tell us that it's still
moving or what might have caused the
movement it definitely doesn't
definitively tell us that that they even
moved maybe this is just a coincidence
that this coast of south america it
looks very similar to this coast right
here of africa now the next clues which
really came over
i would say about the last 60 or 70
years the first clue is that okay if you
go to the mid-atlantic ridge right here
so if you look at the atlantic ocean let
me look at this photograph right over
here so this is it's a little you don't
normally see the oceans highlighted like
this so let me make it very clear to you
this right here is south america
this is south america this right here is
africa this right here is north america
and so if you look at if you actually
look at the elevations in the middle of
the ocean people noticed in the middle
of the 20th century that gee there's a
ridge in the middle of the atlantic
ocean there's kind of a mountain range
that goes straight up the middle of the
atlantic ocean so that by itself doesn't
tell you that that the that you have
these plates that are moving apart but
it is kind of a curious thing to look at
and not only is there's ridge there's a
lot of underwater volcanic activity you
have magma flowing out and lava flowing
into the water and it's kind of forming
this ridge that really goes across the
whole atlantic ocean there are other
ridges in the world like that underwater
ridges you have one over here in the
pacific ocean you have you have these
here in the indian ocean so that by
itself that's just a little bit a little
clue but that by itself doesn't explain
doesn't tell you that these that these
plates are actually moving apart at the
ridge the the more con conclusive you
know this is just the beginning of the
clue but what made this conclusive is
one the separate discovery and this is
what's interesting is that you have
these separate discoveries in different
domains that eventually let you kind of
come to a pretty neat conclusion so
you've had a separate discovery that if
you look at different eras of magnetic
rock or maybe i should say different
magnetic rock from different periods in
geologic time and you can tell we're
there in geologic time by how they're
layered so this would be newer newer
rock
this would be newer and then this would
be a little bit older
and then this would be even even older
even older geologists noticed something
interesting if i were to take magnetic
rock and if it was if it was if it was
molten lava and if it were to harden
remember it's magnetic rock so it would
want to align with the poles the same
way a compass would so if i had a bunch
of if i had a bunch of magnetic so let's
say this is some lava right here and so
you know the the the molecules can align
themselves
since it's when it's liquid and they can
align themselves they're going to
naturally want to align
with the poles so they'll naturally want
to
they'll naturally all want to align in
one direction
one direction because of earth's
magnetic field and so when that lava
hardens into actual rock that that that
alignment will kind of be frozen
now if earth's magnetic field was
constant over time though when you look
at magnetic rocks from any period you
would expect them all to be aligned in
the same direction so if i let me so
since we're taking a cross section of
rock here let's say an alignment an
alignment towards the north pole looks
like this and what i draw it like that
that's kind of an arrow pointing into
our screen and let's say an alignment
pointing to the south pole would look
like this this would be an arrow
pointing out of our screen so what you
would expect is the newer rock that kind
of the alignment the the field the the
alignment of the rock would go into the
screen and then the older rock it would
still go older into the screen let me so
if i were to draw a top view let me draw
it like this just so i make sure that
everyone is on the same page let me just
draw a cross section like this
so what we know we're talking about
let me draw
a cross section
like this and so this is the surface up
here
this up here is the surface when i talk
about going into the page so when i talk
about into the page that means that the
magnetic rock would be aligned in that
direction and when i talk about going
out of the page it means so if i were to
draw it like that
that means that the magnetic rock would
be aligned in that direction now like i
said
if the magnetic field of earth never
changed then lava that essentially
turns into hard cools down into non-lava
rock or you can say freezes into rock it
would all point into the same direction
regardless regardless of when it
hardened regardless of when it hardened
this would be the situation in a
constant magnetic field but what we've
seen is that that's not the case when
you look at older magnetic rock older
magnetic rock and depending on how old
you go you have the newer rock that's
aligned with our current magnetic field
you go a little bit older and right now
we think it's about 780 000 years ago
roughly you have to find rock of that
age magnetic rock that hardened at that
time it's actually in the opposite
direction
so the so it's actually the magnetic
rock has hardened
in a way so that it's pointing it's as
if the it's as if the north pole was at
the south pole now the magnetic north
pole
so it's aligned in the opposite
direction so it's kind of pointing out
of the page here and if you get even
older rock it's more aligned with our
traditional direction so it's more
aligned than that and so the only
conclusion that the only reasonable
conclusion that we can draw from this is
that earth's magnetic field has actually
fluctuated over time
hertz so magnetic field
magnetic field
fluctuates
magnetic field fluctuates now you're
probably thinking sal how is this
relevant to plate tectonics well once
you accept that magnetic fields
fluctuate over the history of the earth
there's another interesting observation
you can make about the rock on the
that's kind of at the basin of the ocean
floor so not only do you have this do
you have you know the middle this this
mid-atlantic ridge do you have these
these volcanoes a spewing kind of new
rock into the ocean creating this kind
of underwater mountain ridge but it also
turns out that the rock that forms the
the sea floor is also contains a lot of
magnetite which is magnetic and what's
really interesting about that so let me
draw
so let's say that this is so we have a
top view just like we have over here so
let's say this is
this is the mid-atlantic ridge right
here so mid
mid atlantic
mid-atlantic or atlantic
ridge now this is really cool so when
they look at rocks that are very close
to the mid-atlantic ridge they're
aligned
and once again we're looking at rocks at
the floor of the ocean they're aligned
in a way that you would expect with the
current magnetic field
they're aligned just like that
the way that you would expect when
you're looking at the magnetic rock
that's close to the ridge
but if you go a little bit further and i
say a little bit i'm talking about you
know thousands of miles but when you go
further out from that you have stripes
of other
you have other magnetic rock that is
going in the opposite direction
when it's going in the opposite
direction it's going like this
it's going like this
and what's even cooler than the idea
that it's switched directions depending
on how far you've gone from the rift is
that there's a symmetric there's a
symmetric stripe of magnetic rock on
exactly the same distance or roughly the
same distance away from the rift that's
also pointing in that same direction
that's also pointing in that same
direction
and you go a little bit further out and
you'll find some rock that's pointing in
the original direction
that's pointing in the original
direction and even better you go on the
symmetric other side of the actual ridge
and you find another set of rocks that's
doing the exact same that's doing the
exact same thing so if you accept if you
accept that earth's magnetic field has
kind of been flip-flopping over time the
only reasonable conclusion at least that
i could think of or that the geologists
can think of is that sure all of this
all of this was formed all of this was
formed at a similar period in time this
came out as lava magnetic lava and then
it all aligned with earth's magnetic
field and that's why it looks similar
you fast forward in time some you fast
forward in time some and the only way or
actually let's not fast forward in time
the only way that these could have
formed and they could have been so
similar so if we rewind in time the only
way that these purple magnetic rocks
could have aligned this way in exactly
the same way at exactly the same
distance if at some point they were much
closer to each other if they were
actually connected so if we rewind in
time
maybe
at the mid-atlantic rift you had all of
the purple rock
you had all of the purple rock coming
out from those underwater volcanoes and
at that time
earth's magnetic field hat was the
opposite as it is right now and then of
course you had this blue rock
you had the blue rock that is looking
like that
and so this seems like a reasonable
explanation this rock and this rock were
at some point touching they were
actually formed at the exact place in
the exact at the same time
and so if if this is the case if at one
point this purple rock was all together
and they formed at the same time at the
mid-atlantic rift we're assuming all the
rock was well we don't have to make the
assumption but if you assume that
they've formed at the same time and that
based on the pattern it really does look
like they do and it's a symmetric
distance away from that rift then the
only reasonable conclusion i can think
of is that the rift has had to move
apart the wrist has had to move apart
from this period to that period and
there was a time when all this blue rock
was together so that by itself that
frankly is the most definitive evidence
in the 1960s where it kind of became
conclusive that you did have these
plates that were moving away from each
other
you did have these move plates that were
moving away from each other and
obviously if the plates are moving away
from each other at some point and that
means that you know just based on where
the map looks at some points they're
also going to be moving into each other
we could talk more about that in future
videos but you know right at certain
points they're actually moving on one
plate is moving another under another
and we'll talk about how that might
partially explain or we'll talk about
all of the explanations for why we think
the plates might actually be moving but
now if we fast forward to more present
times now that we have gps satellites
and all the rest we can actually measure
the movement of the plates this is
actually a this is actually an image
from nasa showing the vector of the
movements at different points on the
surface of the planet and you can say
we've you can see we've gotten a lot of
vectors from the united states so it's
almost it's hard to read since it's so
chock full of vectors
but you can see right over here in
hawaii the pacific plate at that point
is moving in this northwest direction as
measured by gps satellites and i want to
make clear this movement is relatively
slow it's roughly the speed at which
fingernails grow but if you do it over
millions of years that actually amounts
to thousands of miles so it's you know
we're talking on the order of about a
centimeter a year for most of the plates
some of the plates might be moving a
little bit faster maybe close to 10 or
15 centimeters but most are moving about
a centimeter a year at the same rate
your fingernails are going but this is
fascinating because we can actually
measure it because gps is so accurate
over here looks like the north american
plate is kind of rotating generally in
that direction we have you know i could
you know the nazca plate right here is
moving is moving is moving roughly in
that direction moving into the south
american plate i'll leave you there
right now and actually let me just
actually before i i leave you there this
is another thing that i got off a
wikipedia that shows that same magnetic
striping it's maybe a slightly neater
drawing i don't know which one might be
more helpful for you but i'll leave you
there in this video in the next video
we'll think about some of the theories
we know now that the plates are moving
let's think about some of the theories
as to why they might actually be moving